[Music]
the biggest American TV event of the
year will take place next week Super
Bowl 57 in addition to the sports event
and the famous halftime show the
commercials are also a big highlight as
are the trailers for the movie industry
half a minute of air time at the Super
Bowl costs a whopping 7 million US
Dollars we can therefore look forward to
a number of short but elaborately
produced spots Warner Brothers which
traditionally tends to hold back at the
Super Bowl will be joining in for a
change we can still expect at least one
trailer for the upcoming The Flash with
Ezra Miller moreover the rumor persists
that there will be some sort of sneak
preview of the upcoming DC Universe
after James Gunn and Peter saffron as
heads of the DC Studios have announced
some movies and series according to
deadline Universal is set to present two
movies namely Fast and Furious 10 and
cocaine bear especially the announcement
of The Fast and Furious trailer should
not surprise anyone after all the
franchise has always been a pop popular
guest at the Super Bowl in the past
years just before the big event there
will be a fast X party with Vin Diesel
in Los Angeles a launch party so to
speak where the ad campaigned for the
10th film in the series will officially
begin a 15 second spot is planned for
cocaine bear a particularly High number
of trailers can be expected from Disney
these include trailers for Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 and the Little Mermaid in
addition footage of the Pixar film
Elemental is reportedly being planned
Indiana Jones 5 the dial of Destiny and
Captain Marvel 2 The Marvels may also
get their own previews however our
source at deadline did not want to give
a final statement on this Paramount is
also likely to dig deep into their
pockets to promote their upcoming
projects a minimum of three trailers are
sure to be released for Scream 6
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
and Transformers rise of the beasts
still unclear are the participants of
MGM and Lionsgate which would two Top
Class movies in store with Creed 3 and
John Wick chapter 4. however they are
not always represented at the Super Bowl
the same is true for Sony which last
took part in 2017.
[Music]